d'accord on est ce que oui alors on va
expliquer les règles julien lepers voilà
alors franck vous jouez pour la partie
gauche on est d'accord ces riverains par
des droites d'accord celui qui gagne le
jeu d'accord il y aura trois épreuves
fait trois épreuves exactement fait
remporter un superbe jeu vidéo qui sort
aujourd'hui à chaque personne du public
et laura bègue
un jeune fille se déroule alors 3par il
expliqué on va commencer par la première
évidemment ça s'appelle le 4 à la truite
jingle 4 à la question pour un champion
il y en a quatre à la suite nous ont
fait 1,4 à la truite
tour à tour je vais vous poser des
questions bien sûr quand on pourra
trouver c'est quoi vous quand vous
répondez faux tour à tour et c'est à
dire chacun votre tour mercredi répond
défaut je serai à tour leurs adversaires
votre adversaire aura le droit de vous
donner une gifle avec la truite celui
qui répondra aux plus de questions
marquera un point je commence avec la
ville franck attention france c'est la
totale
si je réponds pas je fais quoi de plus
voilà là alors quatre thèmes la saucisse
à travers les âges le camping l'homme
préhistorique et julien lepers un génie
du 21e siècle
je t'écoute
je vais prendre un thème réaliste je
vais prendre le camping le camping tu
connais bien
attention on y va pour 20 secondes de
questions je rappelle qu'à chaque fois
que vous passez au cou vous ne savez pas
répondre c'est une gifle à la truite on
aimait ça continue quand même hein c'est
pas d'accord là c'est ici à temps une
petite seconde comme ça qu'est ce que tu
as dit de ces deux thèmes sur le camping
alors le camping saint tout de suite
quand il te plait il peut par un doigt
trois secondes pendant ce temps-là bouge
chaque bonne réponse vous pouvez
embrasser la truite on est d'accord
non non non ça c'est bon tu danses à ses
dons de l'accord voilà voyons voyons
voilà camping gestion des relations de
parti pas comment s'appellent les tentes
habitées par des indiens d'amérique du
nord
des cycles ou non à 6 par tombe le
peuple à styliser 10 ie8 quel habitat en
dur peut-on louer dans un camping en dur
carbone non
métal permettant de fixer eux tantôt
seul tantôt lot de poissons et de
sardines oui car vincent chocolatées la
préférée de tâter cheryl cole whitt
calme au désir d'un corbeau rudimentaire
et à vivre
c'est drôle
j'étais sympa alors c'est un rêve
la saucisse à travers les âges l'homme
préhistorique julien lepers un génie de
julien lepers s'agit alors attendons je
trouve les connaître par coeur et par
une nouvelle ligne à tort sur deux
bougies pathologies dues à deux bombes
alliées
attention on sait combien la seconde
après la pâte afin qu'ils vous violez
silence total attention pas sûr que la
chaîne ne bouge de lepers présenter
question pour qu'un chanteur le
talentueux julien perret atterri pour le
qatar léonard mais quel est le titre de
ce superbe livre que le pers vient de
sortir le guide des bonnes manières
banon et dans quelles villes françaises
webber s'était vu le jour à quelle ville
je ne sais pas on s'en sort bien que ces
crimes chanson j'ai pour l'art et la foi
c'est quoi
à
mon plus beau
que l'on va
nous fait donc sur cette épreuve de
partout certains combien la saga need et
ce avec une égalité de l'égalité sur
cette épreuve égalité ça fait on voit
partout revenir un craquement
ça va dépendre des deux autres et pourra
alors ça dépend des deux os qui arrivons
alors c'est quoi la prochaine il va
falloir il va falloir abbaoui et ça sent
pas bon alors la lys d'or je crois pour
la prochaine à l'oreille alors attendre
2 secondes derrière rien donc ça c'est
non alors oui perdu alors si l'aîné
frank
n'oubliez pas que vous allez jouer on va
jouer d'avoir dans un moment pour votre
public
chaque plus bas qu'il gagne le prix
ganay gagnera et gagneront chacun le jeu
ils ont craqué la magnifique